Russia's new commander in Ukraine has
made a rare acknowledgment that the
situation in regions the Kremlin
recently claimed it had annexed is quote
difficult Russian forces are struggling
to maintain their grip on strategic
positions in the east and south amid an
offensive by Ukraine kremlin-backed
officials in Harrison region have told
civilians in the city of Harrison itself
to evacuate saying they expect a
Ukrainian push to begin soon the yellow
areas here show territory already
retaken by Ukraine for more let's bring
in our correspondent in Ikea of Matthias
boeinger amateurs how was the situation
there this morning
well it was a quiet night here in Kiev
but we've heard about uh attacks and
closer to the front line on cities down
south and uh
um we've also heard that
Russia was procuring more weapons from
Iran these strikes in the past week have
been carried out a big part of them with
these Iranian Shahed drones so
it was quiet today but that doesn't mean
that it's over yet
and we've heard that the commander of
Russian forces in Ukraine is admitting
that things are difficult in occupied
regions should this be read as an
acknowledgment that things are not going
according to plan
you're not
definitely
[Music]
Ukraine has been attacking the Harrison
region or has been pushing forward on
the Hassan region for some time a
western intelligence has released the
information last weekend that they
expect her son to fall Within These Days
for Ukraine to take back this major city
the only major city that Russia was able
to conquer since February the only
administrative Center that Russia was
able to conquer since last winter and so
what he can saying now that this that he
expects things to get difficult at the
same time the regional Administration
that has been installed by the Russians
on these occupied territories is calling
for people to leave the region or
talking about evacuations
that means that things do really not
good look for the Russians there and
that we might see something either a
retreat or a retake by the Ukrainian
Army in the next few days tell us more
about these evacuations we know
kremlin-backed officials in the Harrison
region saying they are evacuating four
towns
yeah that's uh there have been two or
two of these officials have talked about
that um the fear here in Ukraine is of
course that these might be forced
evacuations deportations of people into
Russia as we have seen them in other
parts of the occupied territories that
the Russians would forcibly drive people
out of there and relocate them to Russia
and in order to maybe assimilate them
later to to the Russian society that
would be a war crime that's the fear
here we don't know exactly what is
happening there how many people are
being
deported if they are deported how many
people are evacuating voluntarily
because they will be fighting of course
there is a reason for people to leave
these areas we don't have the
information but there's a lot of anxiety
about these moves
twice in Ukraine's Capital thanks so
much for that update
so is it possible to end the conflict in
Ukraine with Putin still in charge TW
Sarah Kelly put that question to Nato
Secretary General Jen stoltenberg on
this week's edition of conflict Zone
must Putin go for there to be a
resolution in Ukraine
yes or no
again I will not but you will not force
me to to given the yes or no answer to
that what we will do is that we will uh
respond to the actions of Russia
regardless of who is in charge there and
we will continue to call on them to end
this war it was President Putin that
started this war and let's put the
President Putin and this war tomorrow
while drawing his forces we have to
remember that if President Putin Russia
stops fighting there will be peace if
president zelensky and Ukraine stops
fighting Ukraine will cease to exist as
an independent nation and we don't want
that to happen that's exactly why we
provide support UK well Ukraine's
advances in Russia's losses on the
battlefield appear to be a pressure
point for President Vladimir Putin back
home some key allies are pushing to
escalate the war one of the loudest
Hawks is Chechen leader ramzan khadiroff
recently he called for the use of
nuclear weapons in Ukraine
[Music]
the founder of the shadowy mercenary
group Wagner that's been supporting
Russian forces in Ukraine Ferguson has
lashed out at military commanders and
their tactics the Kremlin has needed to
play down both men's calls for more
Extreme Action and that may have led to
Putin Putin putting a new general in
charge of the war Sergey seroviken he's
known for brutal operations in Syria and
it was just days after his appointment
that Russia Unleashed a barrage of air
attacks across Ukraine
[Applause]
well I'd like to bring in Nikolai Petrov
a senior research fellow with the Russia
and Eurasia program at the Chatham House
think tank in London thank you sir for
taking the time and welcome to the show
um we've just heard a rare admission
from Russia's commander in Ukraine that
things are not going to plan can you
tell us in your view just how precarious
the situation is at the front for Russia
at the moment
I say I'm uh that uh Russian military as
well as President Putin are preparing
public opinion to the fact that Russian
army uh will leave her son uh in order
not to make this uh the third very
symbolic uh failure of the Russian army
in last uh last two months but
militarily it's almost uh not possible
for a Russian army to keep uh well uh
here and so on on the it's come from
so you see an imminent failure for
Russia in the Harrison region do you
think the recent bombardment of
Ukrainian cities is also a move of
desperation on the part of the Kremlin
uh yes right and we do see the war of
attrition and it's understandable that
uh destroying Ukrainian infrastructure
or trying to destroy uh Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure energy
infrastructure Russian army is putting a
hot pressure onto civilians onto
population of Ukraine and it comes on
the 8th of uh the winter meaning that
the idea is to push Ukrainian uh in
direction of uh negotiations and of
ceasefire on Russian conditions a
Ukrainian a president zielinski claimed
on Tuesday night that Russia's
dependence on using drones made in Iran
shows that Russia is militarily bankrupt
what do you make of that claim
I would say that if only Russia now is
not totally militarily bankrupt uh uh
it's moving in this direction and it
didn't already use all sophisticated
weapons uh accumulated and it's not by
chance that we do see tanks and we do
see artillery which comes out of a
Soviet storages meaning that Russia is
not capable now to reproduce those
sophisticated weapons which it lost and
which is which it is losing during the
war
now Putin has been placing blame for
Russian defeats on his defense minister
how long do you think it will be until
people start pointing fingers at Putin
himself
uh who knows today
there is a meeting of the security
Council and there are some rumors there
uh large-scale Replacements at the
soliviki uh block are being prepared but
it's understandable and from the very
beginning Putin did show that it's his
war is his decision and that's why I
think that the idea that he can
scapegoat any military commanders
although in the situation when military
commanders uh before this sudden
appearance of the newly appointed Sergey
Israeli can the absolutely non-public I
think it doesn't work well and Putin
Bear's full responsibility for for all
those failures which are going on so
given that assessment of Russia's
military failures I'm at this stage what
do you believe the Chan chances are of
seeing a coup attempt in Russia
I think that it's too early to speak
seriously about any uh cool attempts and
the reason why is that puts in being uh
well coming from uh security agencies uh
did uh construct a lot of uh safety
Bales in order to avoid this kind of
scenario Russian Elite including
military are atomized are strongly and
directly controlled by security services
so I would not wait for any who to take
uh but no but who knows public opinion
is changing and after this series of
defeats and inability first to achieve
any results to demonstrate and second to
uh well uh formulate exactly what the
real goals of the war which did already
cost a huge amount of human lives this
month and everything else to Russia
Putin will lose his popularity and
against the background of this changing
public opinion behavior of the leads can
change seriously
Nikolai Petrov with Chatham House in
London thanks very much for that
insightful interview
my pleasure